there's a number of things that we're
doing that they get into get into that
space about trying to I mean google news
is somewhat unique in this way I think
every every Google product it doesn't
work if the users don't like it if
people aren't aren't excited about what
you're doing and and and whether it's
gmail or google maps or YouTube or
Google News I mean if you don't have a
product that people want to use you kind
of don't have anything google news is a
little bit different though in that we
have so much of it is is dependent on
our relationship with publishers so we
kind of have to audiences in that sense
so some of the things that we've done
for example we we launched something in
September in Google Labs called fast
flip it's just a one example of this
where we were playing around with with
what is the news consumption look like
how do you how do you change that it
allows you to have these sort of
screenshots and you can just rapidly
flip from one page to the next trying to
marry that offline reading experience
with some of the benefits of online
aggregation and personalization and we
had when we first launched around 20 or
so different titles or sector sorry uh
40 or so different titles from about 20
different publishing companies you know
people like the New York Times and The
Washington Post Business Week and a
handful of others and the response was
really positive and obviously you know
we had to sort of feet figure out does
this is this something that people want
to use and and and the numbers were
really good but also publishers were
excited about it because they saw it as
a different model a different way to to
try and get their content out there and
then just last week we just we announced
that we double the number of publishers
who are participating in this it's still
in labs and we're still trying to figure
out exactly what we're going to do with
this but we were really excited not only
by the reaction that we got from users
but also from publishers because I think
they see that we are continuing to
innovate in this space and now we're
trying to figure out what can we do
together how can we experiment I think
one of the most one of us exciting
things with the conversations I have
with publishers almost all in these days
tend to end with some variation of the
of the statement hey when you're doing
something new we want to be your guinea
pig and for Google that's great because
that's just that's how we tend to
operate so as more and more publishers
kind of raise their hand and say we want
to figure this out to you we don't know
what the right answer is we want to try
something different and we figure that
there are ways that we can work together
to try and do
thatthat's I mean I think that that's
really that's that's probably one of the
more exciting things for me
well I think one important clarification
is I think that we are less concerned
about what the medium is I think what we
care about is making sure that that news
continues to survive that that you know
that Enterprise journalism that
investigative pieces these types of
things that traditionally have come
through newspapers that type of content
can use to survive now whether or not
it's in the newspaper form or whether
it's in a you know kindle or whether
it's online I think we're pretty much
agnostic about how that's done as long
as that contact can use to survive and
so that's that's our real interest is to
try and make sure that the news online
not only survives but but but thrives as
well so it's not necessarily about the
newspaper per se now with that said I
mean I think we're you know we're
looking at all these different areas you
know we continue to figure out how we
can to drive that traffic at we've also
looked at different ways of engagement
fast clip being one example that another
thing that we launched a couple weeks
ago with the New York Times The
Washington Post is another experiment
called the living story page which is
really trying to create a new format for
news so much of what you see online
today is a reflection of what was in the
newspaper just you've taken that article
that was in the paper the day before and
just stuck it online not really taking
advantage of the ways in which you can
tell stories online so this is an
attempt to really just begin to
experiment around a different sort of
format in a different way of telling
stories online tools like that and
experiments like that to try and move
the reader experience forward and then
obviously the business model to you
certainly you can't ignore that and so
you know Google has an ongoing
initiative of just it's quarter our
business about trying to improve online
advertising and make it more efficient
make it more smarter more targeted but
also we are looking at different
business models we've had discussion of
the publishers around subscription
content things that we've already
publicly publicly announced with regards
to google books and the ability to
purchase digital copies of books from
publishers through google I mean is
there a possibility to extend that into
news for example and how could you
leverage Google's technology to do it
that way so I think we're feel like we
a lot in the mix right now and I think
we're trying to think about how we can
move it forward in some of those
different areas